live at four
this is eight news now coveted
restrictions may be behind us and many
who postpone big events over the last
two years are ready to party and that of
course includes weddings that's right
well this is a record year for couples
to tie the knot but as heather mills
reports it's not all roses
wedding season is underway in fact you
probably know someone who delayed and is
now celebrating i literally got like
four words in and started choking up
jesse white and lisa van loo got engaged
last fall and when they started looking
at wedding dates and venues they quickly
realized they'd have to move fast the
owners were saying okay this this date's
now gone this date's now gone and so
almost i was getting anxious lisa and
jesse chose september in california's
wine country to celebrate their big day
which will be one of about two and a
half million weddings in the u.s this
year according to the national trade
group the wedding report the number of
couples tying the knot is up nearly 30
percent from 2021 the most in nearly
four decades i call it controlled chaos
wedding planner joanne gregoli says it's
all due to a mixture of pandemic
engagements and coveted postponed
nuptials i've never seen this many
people who are in need of wedding dates
wedding planners wedding vendors it's
it's totally it's crazy flexibility may
also help couples with the sticker shock
and supply and chain snags food costs
are going up labor costs are going up
event material we can't get glass vases
flowers are in short supply champagne is
in short supply
for lisa and jesse expecting the
unexpected has been an early marriage
mantra for us to be able to come out of
a pandemic and be getting married is
really exciting ending one chapter and
beginning a new one together according
to the knot.com the average cost for a
wedding last year 34 grand this year
that number is going up so the key
prioritize budget and plan
heather mills live local now